Speaker 1: Stacey Abrams has announced she is
again going to run for Georgia governor in 2022.
This is actually sort of exciting. I have to
tell you, I kind of like this. The Atlanta
Journal-Constitution reporting Stacey Abrams
is running for governor in 2022. She launched
her campaign yesterday with a pledge to fight for
economic equality and expand health care access,
setting up a potential rematch against Republican
Gov. Brian Kemp in one of the nation's most
competitive political battlegrounds battlegrounds
rather. So what does that mean? Potentially
a rematch? Remember that there was this crazy
situation where Stacey Abrams ran Stacey Abrams,
Democrat, ran against Brian Kemp, Republican in
Georgia for the governorship, and Brian Kemp won.
What was crazy about that race is that at
the time, Brian Kemp was the secretary of
State of Georgia, meaning that Brian Kemp, as
secretary of state, was overseeing the election
in which the same Brian Kemp, Republican candidate
for governor, was a candidate. Absolutely insane.
Allegations of foul play running rampant and
many concerns that it could be even worse this
time because of something called SB 202, which
we're going to talk about in a moment. Now, why
is it a possible rematch against Brian Kemp for
Stacey Abrams? Well, it's possible because first,
Stacey Abrams has to win her Democratic primary
in Georgia, and secondly, because Brian Kemp has
to win his Republican primary. Now you could say,
David, these both of those things are likely to
happen. I wouldn't disagree with you, but we don't
yet know for sure. Camp has announced he's running
for reelection. Now it's it's cliche at this point
to say it, but the outcome will likely depend
on turnout, as it often does in these state races.
And we now certainly have to talk about S.B. 202.
SB two 02 is a voting law. How can I even
say it's a voting rules law comprehensive
that affects a bunch of different aspects of
voting in the state of Georgia, for example?
As of SB 202, which was passed after Stacey
Abrams lost that race, the earliest voters
can request mail in ballots is 11 weeks before the
election. Instead of one hundred and eighty days,
that's like less than half as much time. The final
deadline to complete an application for a mail in
ballot has been moved earlier. Counties will start
mailing out the absentee ballots about three weeks
later than before, starting only four weeks before
the election. So they're compressing and limiting
the ways and schedules on which people can make
can vote absentee and request those ballots.
Requesting and returning a ballot will also be
subject to new stricter voter ID rules. There are
changes to early voting, which in Fulton
County, which is a key democratic county.
You will no longer be able to use one of
two mobile voting busses in that county,
which were purchased to help with long lines.
Access to those is being restricted, so that's not
good for Democrats. So the plus of this potential
rematch between Stacey Abrams and Brian Kemp
is Brian Kemp will also be the secretary of
state running the election. That's good for
Stacey Abrams. Not so good for Stacey Abrams
as S.B. 202, which is a series of changes that,
on balance, do not help it. Forget about do not
help hurt Democrats straight up hurt Democrats.
I think Stacey Abrams is a great candidate
and one of the things she has going for her
since she last ran are some major
successes. When you look at the two,
what was the date now, January 5th of this
year, special Senate elections in which Raphael
Warnock and Jon Ossoff won defeating Republican
incumbents. Stacey Abrams gets much of the credit
for those wins, participating in massive voter
registration efforts. Successful ones at that.
I think she's a very solid candidate. She speaks
to voters in a way that is both relatable,
but not from a condescending place,
but also really clearly. In that sense,
she's an interesting kind of um, has an
interesting delivery and weight that she
relates to voters. So I'm very excited about
this race. We've got the Texas gubernatorial race
where Beto O'Rourke is running, and there's real
questions as to whether he's the right candidate.
I actually think that's. Stacey Abrams is the
right candidate in Georgia, and we're going to
be following that race, many close very closely
that the midterms are really shaping up to be
very interesting. I was speaking to our YouTube
rep yesterday and I said at first I didn't
know from like a public interest standpoint how
interested will will our audience and the country
be in these midterm elections? Now, as a lot of
these specific races are starting to take shape,
this could be one of the most followed
midterm elections overall in a very,
very long time. Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at De Packman.